next door just here in that right campus
it is and now here's the thing premieres
are all about pulling out all the stops
but I have never ever seen anything like
the total Hollywood takeover of rogue
one oh my god this is crazy i mean the
energy out there the fans i think people
are gonna be pretty blown away just when
you thought a Star Wars premiere
couldn't get any bigger or better you
got a full-size x-wing fighter right
here on hollywood boulevard hollywood
boulevard would close down for almost a
week to make ready for one of the
longest red carpets of the year and it's
dozens of stormtroopers make ten men
feel like a hundred wait to finally be
showing the film's my friends and my
family who I have been like a secret
agent for the last two years this is a
rebellion isn't it in this standalone
story jealousy is the rebel fighter out
to steal plans for the Empire's Death
Star Diego Lunas on her side it's over
it's over two years of secrecy one of
the worst kept secrets after 11 years
the return of Darth Vader to the big
screen I think I'm a pretty tall guy how
much taller was drunk better than me
he's about there he's about I want you
to picture that
you look like you're in a little bit
like it almost like overwhelmed well
it's if I wasn't overwhelmed I wouldn't
be human although I'm a droid in the
movie this is so good and let me just
say this Kate USO steals the movie he is
my favorite droid of any Star Wars movie
ever sorry r2d2